what this little boy endured was said a
judge sadistic
those responsible his stepmother emma
tustin and father thomas hughes were
sentenced over his death all i heard was
a crack off the floor he had he was
heading the floor on all fours judge
wall said this cruel and inhuman
treatment of arthur was a deliberate
decision of both of you you both knew
the extent of his suffering at the time
and were pitiless and indifferent to it
i have seen no remorse from either of
you
it was tustin who'd delivered the killer
blow to arthur's head after
force-feeding him salt
she was warned she could die in prison
for his murder
his father had encouraged her and taken
part in the beatings he was sentenced to
21 years for his son's manslaughter
during the sentencing arthur's
grandmother described him as the
sunlight of their lives but she said
he'd been failed by the very authorities
who should have ensured his safety
on the last day of his life arthur was
so frail from his injuries that he
struggled to walk whether more could
have been done to save him will be the
subject of an independent review what
we've got to make sure now is that we
learn the lessons about that case we
look at exactly
what happened uh what else could have
been done to protect that child in his
early days but i can tell you this we
will leave absolutely no stone unturned
to find out exactly what went wrong in
that appalling case
the abuse began in march 2020 after
they'd hurriedly moved in together
during the government's first lockdown
in april 2020 arthur's grandmother
reported seeing bruises on his back
social workers from solihull council
visited but concluded it was a happy
household and there were no safeguarding
issues his grandmother then told
arthur's school about the referral but
when staff contacted social services
they said they had no concerns arthur's
uncle also tried to raise the alarm
telling west midlands police he had
photos of bruising but he got no reply
then tustin's stepfather made an
anonymous call to social services saying
he thought the youngster was in danger
solihull council says the review into
arthur's death will leave no stone
unturned to understand learn and fix any
issues
this was a very manipulative
step mother who obviously smiled and
said oh it's no it's all fine he just
falls over a lot well you should not be
taking that at face value if you don't
join up with all the other agencies
involved here in a coordinated way and
ask the awkward questions and keep at it
until you get to the truth then it
really is a false economy because more
tragedies like this
happen
this is arthur with his natural mother
who was in prison at the time of his
death and remained so
she said he was her life her purpose her
reason for living
there will be urgent lessons to be
learned from his case
lisa dowd sky news coventry